- [Claire] I'm so
obsessed with it already.
- Everyone at some point in
their life thinks about getting a tattoo.
I've thought about it five times.
(upbeat instrumental music)
Tattoos, I think are magical
just something about 'em
that has the power to heal.
Last year I got a tattoo
to memorialize my aunt
who passed away,
and it was one of the most
empowering moments of my life.
So I want to share that
experience with other people.
Which is why
I'm on a mission to find other
people with powerful stories
and hook them up with their dream tattoo.
Welcome to First Ink.
(upbeat instrumental music)
I'm sure half of the people
in L.A. have tattoos.
Henry, do you have a tattoo?
- [Henry] No.
- And what about the rest of you guys?
Who here has tattoos in the car?
- I do.
- [Ben] How many?
- I have one.
- We are driving from our
BuzzFeed campus in Hollywood,
all the way to Santa Barbara,
we're going to be meeting
Claire, who's a student,
who's going to be getting
her first ink today.
She has a very powerful story.
It's pretty difficult subject matter,
but I went through hundreds
of submissions for this.
Claire stood out the most.
We're gonna hear her story,
which is very compelling.
We're going to find out about her tattoo,
what she has in mind,
and hook her up with some dope tattoo art.
- It's kind of a story with
good things and bad things,
and with this tattoo
I'm trying to reflect the good
things that came out of it.
Around January this year,
I was sexually assaulted by my boss.
I was out getting drinks with coworkers,
he offered to walk me home,
and the next thing I knew
we were in bed together,
and he was taking off a used condom.
When it first happened I was
really, really deep in denial.
I was having anxiety
attacks, panic attacks,
I was diagnosed with PTSD,
and I was still going to work with him.
It took me the longest
time to say it out loud,
and say I was assaulted, I was raped.
Having people there to tell
you, no, it's not your fault,
helped me feel
a lot more comfortable
in telling other people.
So I want this tattoo to
represent the people who were
there for me when I needed them the most.
- [Ben] So you're going to get
flowers to represent friends
and family who supported you?
- [Claire] Yeah.
- This is my studio.
I've been tattooing,
well I did my first one
in like, 14 years ago.
- Is that legal?
- Na, Uh...
My rebellious teen years
sorta led me to hanging out
in tattoo shops at a young age...
- How would you describe
your tattoo style?
- Painterly illustrative.
Floral is my concentration I would say.
Flowers can represent a
lot of different things
and be subtle at the same time,
it's a classic timeless
piece to have a flower.
- When Claire and I first
spoke, she wanted to work
with you the most.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, you're so talented.
- Are you ready to see some designs?
- Here are a few watercolors
that I came up with.
- [Claire] I really like this middle one.
- [Mallory] Okay, Yeah.
I really love the colors on it.
- [Claire] I think the
shape is nice and that...
- Do you like the size?
- Yeah, this is a great size.
- [Mallory] When I put
the stencil on you...
- [Claire] We can adjust it a little.
- [Mallory] Adjust it if we need too.
- That's the one, that's your
first tattoo right there.
You happy with the design,
happy with the placement?
- [Claire] Of course.
- [Ben] That's a substantial
piece right there.
- [Claire] Yeah.
- [Ben] I mean this is no joke.
My first piece was the
size of a quarter, so.
- I'm committed.
- You're jumping right in.
Are you ready to get your first ink?
- Yes.
- Let's go.
- Ready?
Um hum.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- I feel like it's not bad,
but it definitely is
not comfortable either.
It's like if you had a bad sunburn
and someone just kept poking at it.
- [Ben] It looks beautiful,
how have you been coping with the pain?
- [Claire] The first two and a half hours
went by really quickly,
now that it's getting more sensitive,
it's a little bit harder.
- [Ben] How's she doing Mallory?
- She's sitting really
well, I'm impressed.
- I'm kinda jealous right now.
It's pretty addicting.
Addicting, not in the negative sense.
- [Mallory] Yeah.
- In like once you do it,
you wanna do it again.
- [Mallory] Yeah, I think
you get your first one,
you realize that it
wasn't that big of a deal,
you don't think about it that much.
When somebody gets one tattoo,
they really intend on getting others,
even if they don't know it, you know.
- [Ben] We're about four
and a half hours in.
(dramatic instrumental music)
- I wanted to report it
because this was a guy
who was working with some
of my closest friends,
and I was worried that he
would try to do the same thing
he did to me to someone
else that I cared about.
It was arranged that I was
going to have a phone call
with the CEO to discuss the matter.
I wasn't sure if the
company would be discreet.
I wasn't sure if they would believe me.
I was scared of what my coworkers
would think of me if it got out.
I ended up texting my friend
who lives in San Diego.
He, in the middle of the night drove up,
said, I want to be with
you during that call.
The next day my friend
calls me up, and she says,
"Oh my gosh, our boss just got fired",
and I was so happy in that moment.
I had my friend who
drove up from San Diego
and the friend who gave me the
phone call pick out flowers,
lavender and poppy.
My experience was painful,
this tattoo's a little painful,
but you can find beautiful things in it.
- And stuff to help some,
and empower some women
to reclaim their bodies
through the process of getting tattooed,
and it makes it even more rewarding.
- How close are we, Mallory?
- Let me just clean it, and we're done.
- We're done!
You have successfully
completed your first tattoo.
- I'm really excited to
see the final results.
- Okay, do you wanna check it out?
- Oh my gosh.
- [Mallory] You like it?
- I love it, I feel like
I'm in shock a little bit.
I couldn't have gotten a
better first tattoo then this.
I'm so obsessed with it already.
- How do you think your friends
and family will react
to this new addition?
- My friends are really gonna to like it.
My family, they're going
to be surprised at least.
- Are you gonna tell them?
- Yeah, 'cause I don't wanna
have to hide it all my life.
- Is one of your friends here, who...
- Yeah.
- Is one of the flowers?
- I love you.
I love you.
- [Ben] How do you think
the tattoo came out?
- I think it's beautiful.
I think it's everything
I expected and more.
- [Claire] She has lavender
on her ankle as well,
so we're gonna match a little bit.
- [Ben] Oh check you guys out, twins.
- [Claire] So, I hope
that anyone watching this,
who's going through a similar situation,
knows that people will have their back
and they can speak out too.
♪ See you sometime ♪
♪ See you someday ♪
♪ Faraway ♪
- But no, I feel a little bit
like Santa Claus right now.
Yeah, I feel a little bit like
tattoo Santa Claus right now.
Tattoo Santa Claus.
- Yeah, tattoo Santa Claus.
(Claire and Ben laughing)